hey guys I'm Jess McDonald it is the
11th of March you're tuned into gamespot
news and today is what all the game
delays lab sucks first of the delay book
is The Witcher 3 which has been pushed
back to februari of 2015 the game was
supposed to be released in the fall of
this year for xbox one ps4 and PC but it
was revealed in an open letter from CD
Projekt RED to fans that they'll need to
wait a little longer the Deaf have said
that the decision was difficult
thoroughly considered but ultimately
clear and obvious they've identified
that a few extra months will allow them
to enhance the quality that they'd like
to put into the game and deliver more of
what gamers are expecting on games but
most of you guys seem to be aligned with
commented dyan who says I fully trust CD
Projekt RED they know what they're doing
it will be worth the wait next up we
have another big delay this time in the
full of Sony's ps4 racing game drive
club according to PlayStation worldwide
studios exec Scott rody sony has gone
back to the drawing board on the game in
an effort to make it better for fans
rody said they don't want to release a
game before it's ready and evidently it
isn't he went on to say that PlayStation
were willing to eat the cost of
reworking the game and go back to the
fundamentals to make it better you know
because of their piles and piles of
money Brody wouldn't confirm whether
we'll even see the game this year but PR
for PlayStation have expressed that
we're likely to get more details about
the game shortly probably also worth
noting is that driveclub was originally
going to be a ps4 launch title before
its first delay so it's hard to say when
you'll be able to get your hands on this
one lasts up don't worry titanfall on
xbox 360 weren't suck at least that's
according to Microsoft several of our
xbox 360 owning viewers have been a
little concerned about the lack of
talker but what the 360 experience of
the shooter will be like but the
publisher is promising a first-class
experience Microsoft marketing exec
Yusuf Mehdi has said that given the
reach of the xbox 360 far exceeds that
of the Xbox one it was important to make
the former just as in
massive do you reckon just as much
effort will have been put into the 360
version and are you planning to pick it
up you can let me know in the comment
section down below or on my Twitter
where I'm at just McDonald that is it
for the gaming news I've got for you
today but be sure to join me again
tomorrow for more bits and pieces have a
good one